B oh hello Jim Norton the great
brilliant Jim Norton the great Jim
Norton and his wife Nikki are on the
show today they're hilarious they talk
about their transgender love their
TransUnion you're going to love it he's
brilliant it's hilarious she's just a
real Disney princess I mean I I she is
the only femin true feminist I've ever
met she's like I don't cook I don't
clean I take baths all day and I go to
saxs like I love this bitch um uh before
Jim and Nikki I want you to know that I
will be in Eerie Pennsylvania at the
Warner Theater June 28th 2024 come on
out all new material then I'll be in Las
Vegas July singing I'm a singer now July
6 20124 at the Mirage and then July 17th
coming to Canada Edmonton Alberta why
does Canada's City always have so many
names The Great Outdoors Comedy Festival
I'll be there with Bert ker come see us
also I have a new special out it's my
sixth standup special it's called mouthy
it is
on.tv Whitney it's the only fans TV side
uncensored comedy there's no nudity your
wife's not going to divorce you you're
not going to lose custody of your kids
if you go watch it it's a totally
different site
of.tv Whitney enjoy that now enjoy Jim
Norton and his trans
wife big news Jim Norton's married it's
also embarrass that's a very
embarrassing thumbnail but it's kind of
a it's it's kind of a goof we making the
most you are doing the most but we
know I know I kind of know who you're
making fun of in a way yeah like I go
like ah I know the annoying people that
I feel like this is mocking that's how I
normally see his face
but and we're
off oh my God if I give birth this
episode I'll be so mad at you um but uh
I know you're used to getting on are you
used to getting uh after births on no no
no thank God I'll never have that what
is that a tur have you ever had water
broken on your face no it's the one
thing I haven't fetishized is pregnancy
it's the only thing you know what is
interesting I've had more guys ask me
out than in my whole life when you were
pregnant now wow is that weird that's so
weird I don't get it is it cuz I can't
get pregnant I don't know this is that
part of our appeal right now I mean I
wouldn't know I can't get pregnant only
in Jim's mouth all right in okay in La I
think you might be able if you say that
out loud you might get cancelled oh yeah
oh no you can't and you're right in
Norway is there as much bullshit about
this you know it's actually like
nationally it's like if you're
transgender it's kind of like you need a
diagnosis you have to go to the one
Hospital in Norway okay which is called
a national hospital so it doesn't matter
where you're from in the country if
you're transgender you got to go there
to legally start the process with hormon
therapists and psychologist but honestly
I thought it was great for me because I
went there when I was like 145 uh and it
was a long road like 2year process to
get me on everything yeah but it's like
I do think it is the right thing to do
because I'm obviously not 110% normal
like there's definitely something
different going on in the brain and you
know physically and under the
skirt so so it's very weird like when I
came here I noticed that a lot of people
like in here in the states it's not like
that at all you know you can see a
doctor and you can start hormones but in
Norway you got to have a diagnosis it's
called
transgenderism okay diagnosis
f64 Z or something I don't think I know
what the process is here you just have
to be born in Los Angeles to a famous
actress and just say it like I think you
have to be adopted from Africa by a
single famous person I
by the way that's not the big news is
not that we're married like I know that
that sounds like we're we're starting a
YouTube page and that's kind of a joke
that's like the first five minute promo
video stting a YouTube page together is
way more commitment than getting married
I think so too it's so weird to see
myself on like Instagram and social
media cuz I was off the grid for
literally 5 years so now that I'm back
on it's like I met J when I was 19 I'm
26 now it's so weird that just now like
three weeks ago we're public but we've
been together for so long yeah and then
can I ask you like to see a comedian in
love it makes me hopeful it makes me um
a lot of things because I always am like
are we unlovable because of all the
stuff that we have said like put out
there you know I'm like is any man ever
going to want to sign up for that Google
me one time and they'll just never get
an erection again so it's like you know
did you were you nervous after you saw
all of his specials no not at all I kind
of like I remember going to one of Jim's
First shows this was in Canada and one
of his friends so he was on stage it was
a big thing for just for laughs and I
just kind of as a foreign Norwegian
didn't really get get it so one of his
friends go some Americans don't get it
your girlfriend a lot of people don't
get it one of his friends goes your
girlfriend she didn't laugh at all she
was just sitting there yeah he go and I
just didn't get the jokes so I'm now I
kind of get them a little that's how L
you two are you're like no these are
just true statement she's very literal
though she never gets my jokes I'm like
how did you marry a comedian she never
she just kind of looks at me like a
robot psych that's awesome and also
that's such a comedian thing if I'm
performing for 5,000 people and there's
a guy in the front row not laughing I'm
like what are you doing
later you don't think I'm funny we're
going to get along great that's how it
is I I was killing and I just saw one
stoic blonde face and I'm like get a
ring exactly but that guy I didn't know
that guy that well he's a comic and he
goes yeah it was great he goes that
blonde she didn't laugh once I'm like
yeah I know I get it she has
good but like do were you like I I mean
you know like as being a fan of Jim for
so long like The Bravery of being able
to sort of like you know talk about
things most people would you know kind
of like I watch Jim and the fact that he
would just talk about transgender people
in general you know it was for me to see
that it was eye opening cuz literally
like 10 years ago I could never imagine
myself even sitting here or being with
friends of a man that I'm married to
like do you understand I would never
ever imagine that 10 years ago never so
it's weird cuz you felt like you were
being kept like a secret kind of well I
always kind of planned for my life to be
behind closed doors in a way you know
what I mean so it's changed so fast like
when I started out 10 years ago and it's
just 10 years ago yeah but it wasn't
like the way it is now you know when I
told my mom she's like oh you're a
crossdresser a transvest sty like people
don't didn't have the understanding of
of how they do now compared to back then
did you have someone that you looked to
that you were that was in pop culture
like literally when I started youtubing
and Googling the only thing that I found
online was these lady boys I Googled
Amazon like documentaries I'm just like
trying to get smarter before I have a
kid and I'm just Googling like
documentary and I always end up just
watching like another Jeffrey dmer one
but there's one on Amazon it's just
called lady boys of Thailand ladyb boys
and the men who love them I'm like this
is wild oh
Jim that's the only thing that I saw
online where these lady boys and
hormones I just wanted to get in my
hormones I was the clock ticking but
then I realized I have to go to the
National Hospital in Nori so I did and
but the information back then was just
to me at least in Norway just none was
there like anything in the Z like drag
or like were there any TV shows that got
to Norway I I never saw anything of that
etty isard I'm trying to think of like
Amanda laor don't you like even look at
I mean I do China doll I remember like
Jeffree Star was hul
hog yeah I don't know I literally had no
one to refer myself to so it's it's
weird and then you guys start dating
like long distance yeah we talked for
here's the reason we're married now is
because we first started talking CU
you're madly in love I I mean that would
be the I guess but it was more like I
wasn't going to lose this battle I'm
like it was a fiveyear long road and we
started talking at the very end of 2016
and I didn't meet her until May of 2017
so we were we were talking for 7 months
before we face face on the phone on the
phone FaceTime every single day he would
FaceTime me Skype me and we I I only
booked gigs in Norway I literally would
rather you pee on me than FaceTime not
mutually okay so you guys are like
connecting emotionally yeah it forced me
to like didn't know Nikki as a person
and Bill Burr was always on me he's like
dude you got to go overse and I would
never do it but I'm like I'm gonna book
gigs I'll book Oslo I'll book ANP I'll
book uh yeah that's why I first met Jim
was in Oslo when he did his European
tour and while he was on it he was going
to Amsterdam like a week after Norway
yeah um and he was going to fly me out
and I missed my flight but then the next
day you got me another flight yeah so
you hadn't fully transitioned by then oh
yeah still missing flights were we
needed a couple more
hormones but that's fascinating to me I
think because like I do feel like long
distance sometimes helps us not overdose
on each other and not sort of like get
so sexually uh it it was bizar time it
was a crazy time Crazy Life was just
difficult it's I we have something in
Norway called yoven it basically means
you're not to believe you're special
than anyone else we're all equal we're
all the same and honestly I call Bull
you should feel special you should feel
a little special a little coddled you
know and like I heard about this like in
um in businesses over there like the
boss dresses the same as the intern like
you're not wearing a nice suit if you're
the boss the idea is never to stand out
no tall poppy syndrome type of thing
absolutely is that I mean it doesn't
really encourage I guess competition or
anything but I guess if you're getting
paid by the government and pay that much
taxes why would you need to do that it
hasn't translated into our marriage
don't feel better than other people
believe me I would love it she found
Macy's and she's like I love Macy's I'm
like every husband wants to hear I love
more Macy's now B I love it it's great
I'm living the life first when I came
here I was like oh Macy's is beautiful
and then I discovered Sachs and Berg
door and We Share Credit it's got
married we got we got to get this
YouTube channel up and R I gave her a
credit card like I I can't believe my
life is here I'm a married man sometimes
I'll say those words I'm married and it
just it doesn't feel like and it it's
not real it doesn't feel real that I've
been married for well over a year Tim is
really the sweetest person ever this is
correct we this is we all do know this
but I'm curious like what changes like
the day you get married what is there
like a relief is there like a ah I feel
this Unconditional Love Is there a
oh now it's the countdown to when he
murders you cuz this is when it starts
it's it's that you can't leave like when
we fight even if we have a bad argument
I know I'm walking out the door or this
is not an option like I know that we
have to resolve it um but you also feel
like I'm so grateful we been married for
so long that whenever we argue now I'm
like our Union can't take she does that
to annoy me she says our Union I hate it
stop with that shit because the union
points no one lik I don't like that when
we argue that is so F because I do have
this new thing in fights where you go
like are we going to break up if not
this is going to go differently maybe we
can just be silly about like we're not
going to break up right this is like a
deal breaker so why go scorched earth
like why try to hurt each other you
because I'm GNA have to see you in a
couple hours you know but I do think for
me the longest time my leverage was like
well I'm out of here yeah like I'm
leaving you know and that was like just
such a cowardly thing to do like I'm
into the marriage thing there's like
such a like like a bravery to do it I
think now more than ever that more
people are like oh I'm getting married
like half of them and like that makes me
want to do it kind of even more because
it's kind of just like punk rock I love
it I mean I I can't believe I'm saying
that and actually meaning it but I
really love being married like I don't
want anything else this is I love not
having a job and being a house too yeah
we look at it for different no but I
have to say I've never had a job and no
literally I've never had a job I'm not
trying to make myself this person of
weird spectacle but I've never had a job
and I love living with Jim he's a very
manic person so whenever he gets home
from Radio I love waking up early now
yeah yeah which I never did before but
he has a schedule now so when he wakes
up and go to work the first thing I do
wake up have the apartment to myself
coffee you know just relax do all that
but when he comes home the radio voice
is still on and it drives me crazy he's
like Nikki and it's just so loud and
crazy and I've had a nice morning yoga I
do a B Every Morning bubble bath
Waterworks I love it I this is feminism
but do you see the Dynamics I love being
married I never thought i' love it so
much I love having the apartment to
myself no but you know what that's what
marriage is I went through some shit and
I've learned to wholeheartedly
prioritize myself first yeah and being
with Jim it's easy cuz I have the
freedom you know yes I feminism this
this is feminism feminism yes the this
trans women are the only women that are
actually women I'm a bul look at me
working 24 hours a day like I
love song go can you help me transition
into being a woman oh you can I go to
that place in Norway we can both dress
up and listen to uh you'll be a Woman
Soon you know that song yes that just
look at ourselves in a mirror lipstick
man feel like a woman do you know those
posters from the ' 50s where they'll
show like the husband works and the wife
is making eggs she loves that that's she
literally want to be a 1960s housewife
I'm into that too now now that I feel
like I've accomplished a lot of my goals
that's my Kink entirely but also it's
like what is this thing where it's like
cooking and cleaning and women in the
kitchen and that's back it's like you're
using knives and fire and providing for
your man like why is that he is the
worst I was at home I wanted to learn to
bake I can make food but I'm not the
best cake baker and he gets so mad cuz
he's an a DI pointing you're going to
poke me she does that I hate it she does
this and he Y and he yels at me I'm I'm
fat I'm trying to lose weight can you
take that pan off the table and it's
just cuz I am fat and I I believe I know
I put on 20 P I know I'm a pig is that
from being married yeah it is cuz she's
skinny and can eat whatever she wants
and she wants me to die Burn's calories
getting married I know but I eat while I
jerk off I jerk off to the cake I'm
holding that's the problem this fucking
cake is delicious it really offsets any
weight
loss but uh getting fat she can eat
whatever she wants so it's like she'll
have treats and snacks and cookies and
all and it doesn't affect her at all I
have never complained about how Jim
looks never told him look you have to
change you got to go to the gym I never
tell him that never she want she's like
oh you look cute he tells me to change
all the time oh let's go be healthy eat
a little better I wanted to be healthy
not I don't say lose weight but I'm like
I'm not unhealthy if I have a cookie I'm
not healthy well that's just love I
think when you love someone I think for
like people like us like you know we
didn't I didn't receive love in a
healthy way I didn't have parents that
you know showed me how to take care of
myself and then sometimes when I love
someone I micromanage them I also saw a
lot of death and I'm like don't eat that
you're whereas I'll treat myself like
but I need you to stay alive for I think
that's actually one of the reasons why
we work well together cuz my life was
kind of like shit before or whatever so
when I met Jim it's just it's just like
a real person you know who really wants
the best for you and immediately I could
feel the love like the fact that I met
Jim it was just love there is it anger
though like when I love something and I
get scared I'm going to lose it or I
think it's hurting itself I'm like f
what the are you like I don't mean for
it to come out that way but it's just
like I love you so much and if you keep
eating these cookies I'm gonna lose you
and I can't get back on hinge you know
it's just like we it was so Bleak before
you came in there's just the stakes are
high but the control like I and I said
that to Nikki we were fighting recently
I'm like you know what that was me
trying to be controlling and I that was
me trying to control the outcome and I
can't do that like and apologize I
forget we were fighting about but I have
to let Nikki just be herself and live
how she's going to live and up the same
way I up like but the music has to go
which music hers it's it it literally is
Hitler would have tap danc to her
fucking
playlist it's the worst this
is this is it is like like Hannibal
lectors like the music have you heard no
I've heard it yes on the I I put on
stories I clean I have it on in the
background I love it but what is it's uh
what is it it's I listened to some
Norwegian songs from the 60s what's the
one the one I hate so even the 40s all
Saturday all day what's there one that
goes Saturday all week long oh Saturday
how it in Norwegian though how is it
Norwegian to all my Norwegian
fans Saturday all week one it's
horrendous that's living with Jim it's
Saturday all the time I thank God I
don't have bullets in my house for the
gun that I have even looking it on your
Instagram I was like I I would put
there's something about it that is so
joyful in sacran like it's like a parody
of happiness but it's real I come home
and that's what she's listening to
that's where they play FAO Schwarz like
while one of the employees is hanging
watching old westerns yes this show is
brought to you by better help It's the
Most Wonderful Time of the Year unless
you aren't in therapy in which case it's
the most triggering time Time of the
Year this holiday season I'm going to
have a little baby okay the vampire will
be out of my body and I'm already
getting people being like I'm going to
stop by and I'm going to bring you stew
and I'm going to bring you this and can
I swing by and give you a gift and come
meet the B I was what if I was not in
therapy I'd be saying yes all over the
place to these germ riddled weirdos that
want to come see my baby while it's
still
wet okay thanks to therapy I've been
able to say hard pass no I'm not being
rude about it I'm being direct and
honest I don't want me in this little
slug to be in your Instagram story okay
I know why you want to come see this
baby I'm not that dumb therapy taught me
to say what you mean mean what you say
and don't say it mean and to have
boundaries okay I hardly know you if you
bring me a gift that means I now I have
to wash
it I have to write you a thank you note
and not you can't just come hold my baby
just so that you've got a Tik Tock post
go back to the pumpkin patch go to ol
and Mills go to the museum of ice cream
I don't know do with something else for
Content don't drag me my torn apart body
and my baby into your brand strategy
okay therapy has taught me to say no in
a way that is not rude to set boundaries
and not feel guilt about it afterwards
you got to put your oxygen mask on first
before you put it on the person next to
you am I right that is very true but
easier said than done thank you
betterhelp for giving us all the tools
to actually do that betterhelp has an
airline now actually they should start
an a little Airline where they just
literally put your oxygen mask on first
we would do it in a jam up in the sky do
it when you're not in a jam in your
living room if you're thinking of
starting therapy try better help it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com Whitney
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com Whitney it's the holiday season I
want to talk to you about my favorite
company on the planet you know this
about me it's called Etsy if you're like
me you are on a mission to find
handcrafted affordable gifts made by
independent sellers that's my Kink
whether you're searching for custom home
pieces like cutting boards Linens and
throw pillows for your favorite holiday
hosts or personalized items like purses
necklaces and seasonal jackets for your
most stylish friends and family Etsy has
it I'm doing all my holiday shopping on
Etsy it's a goal mind you guys I find
like the weirdest vintage animals I can
find give them to my friends for their
desk or their home or whatever because
everyone loves a vintage animal figurine
and if you don't you can kindly go to
hell you will be dazzled by the visual
Feast of rustic stuff that heals your
heart and fixes your childhood that's
what Etsy does to me if you're new to
Etsy use the code holiday 10 for 10% off
your first purchase that's code holiday
1010 maximum discount value of $50
expires December 31st 2023 see terms at
etsy.com terms for handcrafted and
affordable gifts for everyone on your
list Etsy has it shop
etsy.com I feel like you know when when
people people talk about us or see us
they like think that we're this weird
couple because of the situation but
honestly I feel like we're so normal
like anyone else we're out with friends
you're one of the healthiest couples
I've ever I've ever wish yeah we're out
with friends we go to dinners like we do
everything that normal people do it's
why we like because people like when
when you're in a marriage like ours
people which again is very much similar
to most people's marriage yeah this is
but people are going to assume they know
things about it and that's why we want
to put stuff out whether it's YouTube or
on instagam
it's like if you're going to judge us
watch us and then come to your own
determination based on what you see us
doing I like these two or I hate these
two as opposed to just oh this is what
this marriage is or this is what it's
based on do you know what I mean totally
you want to have your own record of it
so other people aren't telling your
story and and saying what your life is
and what it's about do you feel like you
have to change a little bit some of the
stuff like are you ever like you know
what let's keep this part private like I
guess I'm like in a situation where I'm
a little bit like moving forward in my
life are there s am I am I going to be
able to is anyone going to want to date
me if I air all my dirty laundry right I
keep like she loves the stuff about our
relationship on stage she's seen it and
again she's unbreakable like she laughs
at it and I know I love it she she
actually likes it cuz it's Stu it's I
love it you ever go back to being a guy
let me know
yeah maybe me and you next yeah let me
know Nikki
cumings she doesn't mind me talking
about our private stuff there's certain
things I wouldn't talk about like that
you wouldn't in any relationship
but it feels so good to be talking about
it I'm very open about my life so when I
wasn't talking about our relationship it
was torture remember I remember that
when he was like can we not talk about
this on the show like it really I wanted
Nikki to get in the country and I wanted
to make sure that if we got married we
liked it like we wanted to have a
private life to make sure that it was
good relationship that Jim is a little
like we went to his sister's house when
I first came into the country and it was
Christmas so I felt special and
holidayish and you know and his sister
ceased to ring on my finger my
engagement ring and she asks Jim like
are you married and I'm like wait you
didn't tell your fucking sister we're
married no no this was when we got
engaged we had gotten engaged I forgot
to tell my family you still say
boyfriend so let's just let's just take
it easy my sister saw that and she goes
are you in you're engaged oh and I was
like oh I forgot to tell my family like
I just forgot I couldn't believe it oh
that was an ugly ride home my God that
was a fucking ugly ride home the most
bro M screamed I
but by the way I knew like I KN every
comedian knew you know what I mean but
your sister like I just forgot like it
wasn't such a weird yeah I mean I just
for weird guy sometimes I know when I
told my parents about Nikki we had
dinner and I told them like I met this
girl and I told them she's transgender
and then my my mother wants to know like
are you gay like she again it was she
didn't care but that really is the big
question though like are you gay um no
um I mean I'm not straight but you're
definitely not straight I don't when
your dick is out I don't go
boo well you do but no voice comes
out kids for the people another one all
right but um you know my my parents and
how do you navigate that you're just
like I don't I whatever it is she's a
straight woman I feel like as a man
whenever there's a dick in play um and
you're okay with it yeah it's very hard
to consider yourself heterosexual I
don't care how other people identify but
I just think that Common Sense dictates
if if there's if there's any type of uh
a penis in play and you're comfortable
and okay with that it's not an act of
being heterosexual to no two guys and
one girl is kind of gay what's that I've
always thought thre STS with two guys
and a girl it depends on if there's dick
touching or or or you know mouth how do
you miss that how do you it depends I've
seen them where there's like one on one
end one on the other end but if they're
together a little bit but then they're
looking right that's right that's I
contact that's I contact which is even
gayer than Dick's touching you know so
any man who dates a transgender can't be
straight there is just no way it's I
it's it's hard to see being straight or
you like dating women that are women
just cooler just less sensitive and
annoying I don't like I don't but I
don't care what it's called like I don't
it doesn't matter to me whatever it is
like I'm fine with it either way if it
if if if it turns out someday someone
said you're totally het great I wouldn't
believe that but I don't how other
people look at it or how they ID message
though that the general people are
trying to come across that real woman
like let's not pretend you're sitting
here so pregnant that we're the same
person right right cuz we're not like I
don't get period hello like why do I
have to explain that yeah you're a
transwoman and I'm a trans
man I got it but it is yeah I mean it's
also interesting because it's like I
have a lot of friends you know in La
that are dating guys that wear v-neck
and bracelets and they go to Coachella
and they're actors and they wear makeup
and I'm like you're not totally straight
if you're dating him but whatever dude
I'm not you know what I mean none of my
business and people get so mad at you if
you give an answer that is not 100% I
put you in a box just help me put you in
a box every group has their thing where
if you're not 100% in line with the
ideology you're an enemy if you're if if
if you question or don't check every
single box of the of the ideological
belief you're an enemy and it's crazy
well also I can't think of anyone in
who's a dlis B Lister C Lister I don't
who's married a transgender I can't
think of one person I've never heard of
it I've never read it and you know Jim
do it Smith
where I feel like I could think of a
couple H but there's also an argument
that you know I know a lot of athletes
that date trans women and not
necessarily publicly whatever exactly
it's still a thing that is kept behind
closed doors but the whole point because
I'm I just did this special that's
coming out this week and I did it for
ofv which we did the roast for they're
doing comedy specials now totally
uncensored I talk about trans people for
like 30 minutes and just the whole sort
of thing and um and I asked them like no
judgment just what's and they're like
trans women are the only women that
actually are feminine anymore their high
heels and the skirts and you know they
do the hair and make I think a lot of
trans women are obsessed about the ultra
femininity yes whereas like is like I
just like the a kid from stranger like
you're actually a gay pedophile if
you're attracted to me you know and like
straight men look at trans women and
they're like that's what a woman's
supposed to look like why did you what
did you guys start wiar Crocs but they
they put it in everything their walk
their posture their lips everything
really go for it and they know how to do
it well like men do yeah there's like a
hyper femininity that that women that
aren't trans have like that's toxic and
we like grow our armpits out now and we
all you know I also think that a lot of
the athletes and I can't speak for all
of them or the women they date but I
think a lot of them are just trying to
write off the fact that they like dick
too I think a lot of them are trying to
like pretend that that's not a reality I
me we all know how big shim porn is like
let's not pretend that so many men are
watching it or anyone and it's like I've
never seen a relationship like this
where a public person has really done it
you and it's that Jim out of all people
is the one who's the liberal person in
the picture I mean being who you are I
wish that they would just be like date
who you want to date but I I just hate
the fact that it's always somebody gets
caught with somebody trans it's so
annoying it's like just shut the up and
date who you want to date people are
allowed to have private lives I'm not
saying that people should out all their
private sex sure people have Private
Affairs with
non it's the idea that people just never
say it and it's like just own a lot of
men love trans people and the dick and
all that and the balls all of
it but some of
these yeah you don't exclude those
you're
right and also it's like women that are
were one men at one point with balls
were kind of like yeah but now you're
with this woman and you a lot of these
guys also like vagina and they're like I
will never give up vagina I can't do it
then how are you going to be in a
relationship like they land back on the
wh you know I think a lot of guys are
like that too yes but I think the desire
always comes back if you like it once if
you want to know like there's so many
and again I would never say people's
private business I don't believe in that
but there's so many people that I know
feel a certain you obviously hate
YouTube reue I think some trans creates
a tingle in some of these men and we all
know but they won't they just none of
them say it uh and I wish that they said
it because it would make life a lot
easier for people it wouldn't seem like
such an like a different thing if more
people were like oh yeah that's I like
uh this is who I date that's who I did
it wouldn't seem as uncommon and that's
all I I just think that you know you're
you're hiding it and you're afraid of
people going to find out anyone in my
life who didn't accept who I was with I
would immediately remove from my life
anyone family anyone who had a problem
with it would be cut out of my life
immediately it's also weird because sex
is like you know I'm about to reveal a
lot about myself best case scenario it's
like a half hour a day oh wow what what
was that a lot or a little oh my God
yeah we're faster
okay 30 minutes that's I mean a few
pumps 30 minutes wow still plenty of
time to watch the end of family
[Music]
Twi and so like best case scenario so
it's it's like sex is like the like 2%
of the time you're SP spending with
somebody but it's thought as like the
only thing that defines what you're
doing which is what weirds me out with
people now that like I know it's going
to get me in trouble fine um but when
people are like oh so and so and this
person's we need to hire someone who's
gay and that's like I'm not thinking
about where their dick goes that's like
such a weird thing to open with it's
like me she she her they that and you're
just like I'm I wasn't even thinking
about who you but it's so weird that now
that has to be like defining factor of
your identity I'm watching these
pronouns and stuff she her like fine you
know I think it's bringing the message
across but it's like if I say that I
just feel like what like why would I I
just think the whole pronoun thing is
crazy like I went to an LGBT convention
in Canada actually because I had no
friends so I wanted to make friends
other trans people and it was the
craziest thing like they're all wearing
latex
pants yeah pink beard I just couldn't
relate I'm like this is not who this
this is on another level than what I am
this is something else you know but also
girls like not all girls get along you
know what I mean like I there's a lot of
it's the most catty
jealous society that I've ever touched
and I'll never go to another convention
it's literally I know that I walked in
there not to come in my white horse or
whatever but I knew that I was standing
out tall blonde whatever yeah all the
trans women are going to hate you by the
way all the non-tr women are going to
hate you and some group grp of them were
laughing at me and it's just that
jealousy it's like I was there to make
friends you know no no no no no you
can't blonde pretty blond don't have
friends I'm sorry I just wanted some
friends Hitler wouldn't have killed you
um he would have suck my dick oh yeah
after he fucked you and was jealous of
the fact that you had two testicles cuz
he only had
one but there was a there was this show
on it was National Geographic it was
called a small light and it was about
the Holocaust and is a really beautiful
show and they showed like what the
happened with the gays uh in the
Holocaust which we don't talk about as
much and there were all these Nazis that
would sleep with Jews to prove that they
were gay or sleep with gay people and
then come back and be like we got to
kill this guy he's gay and I'm just so
curious how they picked the Nazis that
had to you probably wish you were in
Holocaust or did you volunteer volunteer
like I got like how do you volunteer to
be like I'm going to
go gay ones to let you know which ones
are gay but how do then you not what
veiled homosexuality that is look I'm
I'm going to this prisoner just to see
if he's gay I mean yeah turns out he's
super gay I did nothing for me yeah uh
you know I didn't care for it at all he
made me come in 30 seconds so you got to
burn him alive like I like I'm obsessed
with those Nazis the ones that had to
like I never heard of that yeah they had
to like sniff out the gay dudes we were
occupied by Nazi Germany in nor Norway
was oh yeah yeah so in the hometown
where I'm from there's like little
bunkers and didn't your mom take us to
see that like where all like where all
the soldiers were fighting the Nazis
from yeah they got uh I'm from a very
small City uh it's like the countryside
with lots of horses I'm a farm girl
originally they were like let's go to
where the blond are Scandinavia never
seen a clothing dryer before I came to
the states so that was I love I love a
drw that was how I got her here I just
dangled dry clothes that's how I got her
to the states I'm like hang them on like
the wire and married El now I only do
the tumble dry yeah the dryer you never
seen a dryer before the dryers are
insane I love them I've never seen one
talking to Tinkerbell dude like what
that was all it took to get her the
states I'm like you want to get rid of
that fucking wire in the living room
just Easy Living you just like married a
Disney princess it's like such a mind
fuck Birds Landing on her fingers she's
drying with your
sweaty black shirts y Jersey mustard man
yeah there a lot of piss that's yeah
it's I know I'm gross we the same old
shirts when you came over here that was
probably like the peak of what was going
on with like the trans drama in the
Zeitgeist are you just like do I have to
say being in the states like in New York
especially I have not had one comment I
have not had one person look at me weird
not it's they're not like you're taking
my daughter's trophies it's it's a very
very liberating feeling to walk New York
like compared to Norway even which is
legally you know great but the people in
Norway in my opinion are much more
conservative so being in the state I I
love being trans into States I think
it's great everyone knows what it is
it's not some weird did you see that
they banned trans uh women from chess
they did I don't know why chess is split
like between men and Wom just saying
like you'd be smarter it's so silly like
I don't oh why is chess even between men
and women there should be one chess
champion there's no physical I don't
know I
mean sorry hot take here I it's I I I
can't even open the box Pat you gave me
the chess box I can't even figure out
how to F I know I've been begging you I
don't even know how to open it I mean I
think you know it's kind of like men's
Brains I guess more mathematical is
their point and women's a little more I
can't win a chess game by crying and
making me feel
bad I can't emotionally manipulate you
into into moving the little chips I
don't know I see the CH little chips
know you call the chest pieces the
little chips oh I was thinking of
checkers but even them even them they're
Checkers that's in the name of the game
is what they are they're fucking
Checkers I thought it was the little
poker chips oh the little
chips they are Checkers oh so this is
like the king and the Queen and the
horse sure and the Knight and the bishop
and the rook and the yes a lot of Chess
I do I love it but I think that that
that's one of those things where it
should just be a genderless sport
because there's no physicality to it
yeah that is bizarre I think people
freak out when it comes to like MMA like
is a is a trans woman GNA punch a
physically yeah I mean it's like
fighting I would be nervous to see a
woman fighting somebody trans it's can't
we just be reasonable get HT we all know
the difference yeah and then also by the
way um can Elliot Paige win an Oscar for
crying on
camera right you mean as is that an
advantage as a woman you mean or as a
man as a man transitioned to a man oh
Ellen was became Elliot right Ellen is
Elliott now and would compete as a man
in the Oscars yeah but if you're a
better actor better at emoting oh right
is you know what I mean yeah is it kind
of like is it kind of like a previous
man playing a sport I don't know I I I
it's like it's gotten so and and and
everybody is so invested in the answers
and so mad at each other for not
agreeing 100% on the answers that it's
like I I don't even know what to think
about half I just all I hear is people
screaming at each other and everybody is
like if you don't see it 100% my way
you're an absolute enemy and fuck you I
think it it's also only people that have
no real problems that want to fight
about this and it's also with the
hormones and stuff like how in America
can you expect to get all these free
hormones and free health care if there's
nothing wrong with you like that doesn't
make sense to me so I actually think you
know where I come from and you I'm not
saying it's perfect but even in Norway
trans people are saying that our system
is so wrong I don't really think it is
and let me ask you so you went in and
did you have to like talk to therapist
you had they looked at her playlist and
they said yes you're in a full group of
therapists you're also trans age and in
Norway you can like send in a message
and request all the journals and
information that doctors WR about you so
of course I did and they're like oh she
likes to do makeup she has long hair
looks like a woman comes off as a lady
so they're really like I've hear a lot
of I've seen a lot of articles in Norway
where people are like they're not giving
me the help that I need I'm a real trans
person they're saying I'm not but I
think well the key to being a woman is
men not believing
you so that means she's definitely a
woman if they don't think she's a liar
yeah I just think there has to be some
psychology in the picture I think it's
reasonable so like you go in at 14 and
they're asking you questions asking even
sexual questions and all kinds of
questions right I'm just so happy that I
just did this and didn't go under the
knife right you know what I mean because
I don't feel like there's nothing else
wrong with me physically right if I want
to I can I saw a doctor in Boston who's
like a facial doctor very recognized
very like famous and I went there I was
so pleased cuz since 13 I've been
wanting to see him yeah and I'm sitting
there and they're great and all but I
just see the cuts would be here the cuts
would be and just I'm happy that I did
didn't do it cuz I literally thought I
would forever I would whatever Nikki
wanted to do I'm comfortable in my own
skin finally you know but I would always
go I would always say just don't like
you don't need anything done you don't
need but if you want to do it like it's
your body but kind of the trans there's
non-trans women that do that also
they the tranny code like you have to
get these things done if you want to be
a real trans but then I feel trans
people are so different like females to
males and males to Fe it's like day and
night so different and we don't get
along some time no one cares when it's
female to male right people are like
that's just smart yeah it's just a good
idea no it doesn't bring out the same
anger for some reason you're right it
just doesn't I I guess it didn't with
lesbians neither gase lesbians were
always more than gay yeah yeah yeah
lesbians were always easier for for
people to process than gay men sure I
mean I I fight with a lot of my transg
girlfriends cuz when they're going in
for another surgery and another surgery
I'm going to fight with you the same way
I would fight with one of my non-tr
girlfriends about getting another
surgery and another surgery going like
you look gorgeous this isn't what women
your butt doesn't have to look like that
as a community it's very compulsive I
feel like like get this done do it you
love it or sometimes it's like is there
any like feeling of like making up for
lost time because I think I know a lot
of trans women that didn't get to
transition till like their 40s and then
all of a sudden they look like Betty
Boop and I literally think that some of
these girls literally do it cut off the
bottom just to look good in a bikini and
that's insane or just wear jeans right
right okay just for that if you want
like if you want to get rid of it get
rid of it like whatever you want is f i
don't here's the difference levels of
transgender people some of them want
that 100% some of them look down and
scream in agony there has to be
different levels totally but just like
knowing what is gonna because like doing
it and then regretting it that's going
to be rough yeah especially for Jim
could you imagine oh
divorce what are these folds I'd wheel
her out of the hospital run into my
lawyer's office I cannot wait to see
this show this is my dream but honestly
it's only us just being like it's like
it's I hate to say Slice of Life stuff
but it really is just pieces of Our
Lives um like we you know we went on
bird this is just an announcement like
we both suck so much at promotion but
this was just to let people know hey
there's a YouTube channel coming um
there's no great the Jim Norton Nikki
Norton Matt about you is I'm on the edge
of my
seats I hope people like it I I mean I I
uh I really do she's my favorite person
on Earth and we have we genuinely have I
love you too I just love that now people
will finally get to see how we
communicate and a lot of people are like
Jim Norton is just a lot of people are
just and I'm just happy that comments
but I don't read them ever but by the
way this is something we find Nikki is
very literal and says things there's
never a compliment that feels good it's
like she said to me recently you know I
think you're really cute why does so
many people say you're ugly and and she
like with no irony whatsoever no irony
yeah she was genuinely being a loving
wife and I'm like I don't know do you
want me to Hash this out or should I
just hang myself in the fucking
closet that was a real question yes it's
like it's so sincere and genuine yeah
here's what else did you say to me we
were watching something I forget what
the guy was doing it was Macho and she
went I'm so glad you're not an alpha I
am though I don't want an alpab man I
know that but I don't want to be I just
don't want that obviously but nobody
wants to be
Jim is very cute my God that's just so
funny because you can't be mad because
you're I know you're saying something ni
she means it very lovingly she's like
very she accepts me perfectly as I am
I've never complained about Jim ever no
she doesn't like I hate the way I look
right now I know I look gross and fat no
one thinks that but Jim but but
literally she's it's genuine I know
Nikki W off and she'll tell me you look
great I'm fine with that and then
there's a part of me that thinks no she
wants you to have a stroke fat boy so
she gets the apartment no then I would
have just poisoned you
yeah after this next tour maybe we let
me just get some once you get that
YouTube Revenue going to the Norwegian
bank account oh hopefully Two Broke
Girls was in Norway was it oh I think I
knew that yes I watched out when I was
like nine a little oh my gosh okay
that's one of them yeah she just did it
to me oh yeah yes without mean she just
did it to me when you make someone feel
old when you say I watched that when I
was
nine F
brutal well I think I was do you know
what it's like knife to the heart do you
know what it's like when I'm putting a
kiss poster and she like oh my God my
father would love that he's younger than
you yes that was such a nice way to call
me old in a way that you didn't even
mean it that's my life that's exact it's
never mean it's always meant to be
loving but uh yeah she's she's great I
mean Nikki is not I I I one of the
reasons we work is because her sense of
humor is so good um she is legitimately
funny and she makes fun of me and she
never she's unbreakable if I make fun of
it's like it's it's the way I very
important to have Irony when you're me
you know cuz if you don't hey y'all if
you've not had a kid there's more to
look forward to than you thought you
don't just have the privilege of
wondering if you will perish in
childbirth or if both your holes might
turn into one hole you also get to have
bleeding gums every time you floss you
heard me every time thank God for quip
which makes this genius water flosser
which has a cordless rechargeable
battery that lasts up to 8 hours with
daily use no bulky charging dock or
Tangled cords no Marauder can kill you
with your own hygiene products thanks
quip that's a huge plus this is the
water flosser it blasts away up to 99.9%
of plaque from treated areas with
Precision thanks to the 360 Dee rotating
magnetic floss tip that snaps right into
place easy to control water flow that
leaves you feeling squeaky clean sleek
and slim enough to keep on your
countertops and keep your countertops as
clean as those sexy teeth you already
know I use the toothbrush religiously
the equi electric toothbrush is loved by
over 9 million mouths I'm not going to
make a joke about what else is loved by
over 9 million miles with stylish and
Affordable Electric brushes starting at
$25 you will not be paying through the
teeth for better oral health if you go
to getquip.com Whitney right now you're
going to get 20% off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser or
water flosser that's your 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com Whitney that's get
gq.com Whitney equip the good habits
company so when I started podcasting an
online store was the foest thing from my
mind now I'm selling all kinds of things
notably my book it is so easy to sell
all because of Shopify so if you're not
a Shopify Merchant it is such a
GameChanger Shopify helps you do your
thing however you cha ching it is the
global Commerce platform that helps you
sell at every stage of your business
from the launch your online shop stage
to the first real life store stage all
the way to did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is where you grow
whether you're selling sended soap or
offering outdoor outfits or making humus
or are as insane as me and wrote a book
Shopify helps you sell everywhere from
their all-in-one e-commerce platform to
their in-person POS system wherever and
whatever you're selling Shopify has got
you covered Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce companies you're going to sell
more with less effort thanks to Shopify
magic your AI powered Allstar so I love
that Shopify has this tab it shows you
all of your your orders in a super clear
way the names the cities that were
ordered from and you can directly
message certain people to sort of see
the tracking you can send a mass email
to all the buyers if something is
delayed or if you just want to send a
special thank you for you know your
business type of thing it's a way to
kind of like make it all manageable for
like my crazy ass brain where I can't
follow what's going on makees it very
clear and then you can use the data you
see to amplify your business other
places like I can you know go like a lot
of people Tampa bought my book I should
do a show there or open a Senior Frogs
franchise something look at me taking my
business to the next level Shopify
Bowers 10% of all e-commerce in the US
and Shopify is the global force behind
all birds rothis and Brooklyn and
millions of other entrepreneurs of every
size across 175 countries sign up for a
$1 per month trial period at shopify.com
Whitney all lowercase shopify.com
Whitney go there now to grow your
business no matter what stage you are in
shopify.com
Whitney I never even imagined that I
would be a wife ever so I'm just loving
that I'm a wife I wake up I cook I make
eggs I'm just doing all this wife stuff
that is so common and I love it it just
makes me feel like a wife and some
people will say delusional but if it if
it is I'm living why delal why is there
shame around loving your man some people
would say that my whole life is a
delution you know look at you but
honestly if it is then I'm living the
dream I'm still looking for friends in
my own little circle you know not being
on a social media throughout this
time very hard for me to make friends
like where at the gym like no very hard
so I'm still exploring that and it's
going to be so much fun I'm very excited
it's such a fun time I'm literally
giggly all the time so cute her friends
are my friends and it's like a bunch of
old guys I don't want to be around with
another 60-year-old man all the time I
want to be with better way to with the
gires where are they come through cuz
the people who follow me now are only
gim trucker fans get a boob job you
should get boobs and it's like that's my
Al Throw Some D's on that bitch that's
Jim
Florentine so that's where I'm at now
get a boob doob but you know yeah they
say that sometimes like I don't do jobs
I was very clear I do no jobs zero kinds
of jobs had a job I love
that's my favorite thing never had a job
no I Aspire I've been a lot of things
but not a worker no not a worker no at
home I do clean home she I mean it used
to take you two and a half days to do
your laundry so I guess it's yeah moldy
I don't fucking get get get a what are
some other things about America that are
a delightful because I I think it's it's
Americans we take for granted this great
country we live in and so it's nice to
talk to someone that yeah what's I well
this is is probably not an American
thing but when I moved in with Jim he
had a Toto
toilet and now the this the the seed is
heated oh my God so now sitting on a
porcelain one feels foreign she said
that to somebody know what I mean Nikki
here's Nikki she has no idea how
arrogant she sounds sometimes she said
who did you say that you were talking
and you go Laura you said God sitting on
a non-heated toilet feels foreign you
understand how shitty that sounds hold
on
You' Just Married Marie antoinet I
really it's just so funny to me like
it's just like cracks me up
pity that she lives in if you came home
and saw her in the bath with the fucking
things on the with zero irony it's like
this is the life I should be having big
Periscope poking
up telescope I'm just obsessed with you
heated toilet like doing the damn thing
steam showers it's great yeah she loves
all but I think Americans are really
nice people like at least everyone that
I've met they're just so nice so cool
not awkward people like they're not
stiff and weird and hello like they're
done in Norway like oh hi it's just
fucking weird Norwegians are a little
like I don't want to talk to you and
they don't want to talk to me neither
hello how are you it's just Bye by the
way it's the angriest language it's it's
not a pleasant language Norwegian there
is but also um Norway is kind of
fascinating because you guys found oil
right and instead of do oh my God we're
literally so so inad of doing what
fucking Saudi Arabia did and just like
chop a bunch of cre a pension fund with
all our oil and put it all in a trillion
US dollars I think that's pretty good
for a country with five million it's
pretty cool so it you free education
right yes and free housing or and free
health free education up to like college
or something uhuh how is it though it's
good no it's good it's good I I love the
schools in Norway they don't have
shootings if you but this is if you're
driving you don't understand the Fury
you feel when you're driving and you
hear the phone and you go H here's some
fun facts about Norway and it's
literally nothing but bragging about
Norway that trillion doll thing and how
much each nor I heard that so many
fucking times I'm very proud to be
Norwegian is she loves being nor why is
everyone so awkward I don't know I think
maybe it's a Nordic thing that we're
very reserved I want to go to slar Bard
oh my God that's an island above Norway
that's Norwegian and in swart you always
have to carry a rifle because there's
polar bears there's more polar bears
Than People yes you need a per you need
to carry one I've been watching this
lady on YouTube she lives there actually
oh we're watching the same lady I love
her Cecilia and something else I love
about it is like 11 men a year die there
because they're like I don't need a gun
yeah like guys will just like I'll be
fine polar bear a year ago I think it
happens all the time and since I'm
Norwegian I can legally move to swart if
I apply so Jim maybe we can reside with
the polar bears it would be PR sometimes
you know there there are times where her
level that it's an episode for sure of
the show she'll say to me like I just
want to like let's buy a Norwegian cabin
I'm like you don't understand how
unappealing that is to me like I want to
live in the city or La I don't want to
live in nor half of Norwegians with 5
million H 50% owns the cabin that's very
important in Norwegian culture I think
Jim would love it a Norwegian cabin
decorate are there a lot of murders
there or no no I associate C we don't
have a single ghetto there's no gangs
wild yeah it's very ni they're nice
people you know what else nor uh Norway
has I always want to call it norwegia um
is the seed bank so yes in smallart
every seed wh I love you how you know
all these Norwegian facts there's a
reason I'm single and you're not um this
is all I they call my
stomach that's my
uterus oh God bank would imply there was
money involved um for this but uh so so
if there's a nuclear war every seed in
the world is in Norway two million seeds
and it's beautiful to like start yeah I
don't know I can you T it I I think
there's a tour you can't go inside
though I don't think they allow no
there's a tour but you can't go inside I
that's my dream like obsessed it you go
all the we're very eco-friendly and all
that and very like prepare I think
that's they know some sh we days we have
like life fish which we still eat Lisk
which is which is like Li fish Lisk it's
like a fermented or it's like a Cod that
lays in lie and over the times you put
salt and you have to just salt it shock
salted if that's an English word for
like weeks and then you eat it so I
think Norwegians are are good to prepare
for the winters and the cold times yeah
now with the oil fund the seed Vault I I
see uhhuh the progress I'm just
fascinated by like like Norway Sweden
fin they all it's like kind of like
States I think every state in America
feels a little bit like a different
country have you been to other states in
America that you're like what the fuck
is this it's so different i' I've been
on the road with Jim a couple of times
and there's places where I can't even
get a fucking caar salad like it's
insane yeah you've been to Cincinnati
yeah been to Cleveland we've been to
obviously La San Francisco Gilford New
Hampshire bir show oh nice uh Florida I
mean that's like going to different
countries basically yes yeah we've been
a lot we've been to we've been to France
we've been to Iceland we've been I want
to go to the South sometimes maybe South
is awesome yes have you been in Texas
yet or no no no not yet oh you'll do
great in Texas oh yeah you think they
will love you yeah this is like Dallas
like this is what they want there really
yeah what's Texas like cowboys and stuff
Texas is like very independent thinking
people that are conservative more
conservative a little more conservative
but also really fun like like right now
we're at a place in our country where
the Liberals are not fun anymore you
know the Liberals used to be like the
free the blue States used to be like the
Free Speech people the you know no
censorship people now conservatives
they're the ones you can I think really
go harder at in terms of Comedy that
don't take themselves so seriously and
that aren't so like committed to
everything being they're not looking to
punish you for every joke you tell even
if they find it offensive that's right
or gross they're not trying to have your
life ruined for jokes that they know are
jokes but since they can't stop you for
telling jokes they pretend that there's
a higher Social reason to punish you for
they're not addicted to self-righteous
indignation and judging people they
don't think they need to have an opinion
about everything all the time so like
see behind you those cowboy boots like
they wear like cowboy boots like I uh my
mom grew up in Texas and uh is from
Texas I spent a lot of time there it's
kind of also people that are kind of
like you mind your business I'll buy
mine yeah you know what I mean and
they're kind of like like not my
business just get off my lawn if you do
I'll shoot you but like I won't come on
yours either you know it's do they all
have guns there in Texas is that cuz in
Florida we were just in Sarasota and I
learned that everyone carries there 80%
is the same in Texas they carry 80% oh I
don't know if it's 80% do you want a gun
yes see this is what B like I she's this
is true she's the only person and and I
reloaded in Jim's mouth
um uh shoot up that school there's uh
there's a I forgot what you going to say
now uh with guns I want a gun I want to
have it in my night drawer I live in New
York I'm not saying that we're going to
get robbed we can't have a gun she's the
only person I've ever seen knock a
bottle off a shelf in a supermarket with
her elbow I've never seen a person do
that d a car no I know because you're
you you bump into shit never worked I've
never driv that's the New York thing by
the way most men in New York they're
like I'm a New Yorker and I know every
subway system and I know every and they
get in a car in LA and they're just like
an Asian lady and you're like oh Jesus
Christ he's a crazy driver he honks he's
not an easy traveler at all flying
driving but driving in New York he honks
like a maniac but I'm a good driver he
is a good driver thank you I bet but
what are you worried about your safety
no it's just watching I'm what I'm
worried about is him getting into an
argument with another driver like a road
range yeah I worry about that too I'm
careful with that okay um although last
we had thing last night when we do Uber
sometimes and the Uber driver is slow I
fucking hate this I'll sit in the back
with Jim and he goes come
on go on and like he wants him to hear
it but he's whisp what's your Uber
rating stomach it's it's four something
it's pretty good it was pretty good
which I can't understand surprising cuz
he'll go like
this we had that we were at the ivy last
night eating dinner and there was a loud
girl's birthday like they were you know
yeah yeah but it was sweet yeah 14 and
the okay older couple next to us older
table people just they were a little
annoyed and eventually the guy just
snapped screamed on top shut literally
and the whole room went silent silent
and and the girls were just hulking like
I I felt like At first so bad at first I
was like ah well whatever they were
being annoying Rift in my but I felt so
bad for them when I saw these girls and
then like their party was ruined like it
wasn't like they just laughed it off
like I would have when I was 14 like
fuck you old man like they were like if
I may when I was 14 we went to Houston I
never went to the ivy yeah we were we
were at Cheesecake Factory I mean I I'm
they were living their dream if I'm that
guy though not related to them right he
wasn't like some jerk off here the
annoying part cuz this lady was she's
wearing the Chanel Pearl she's probably
been to Ivy what 80 times and these
girls are just having fun if it was my
first time with Ivy and I was
paying they were they were really it
ruined their night and this bully jerk
off wouldn't have done that if they were
bikers like you I mean that's what he
screamed at he didn't say hey ladies can
you keep it down little why can I ever
see you naked yeah I exactly I hope he
get killed in an accident on the way
home I hope he fucking died I really
I fucking hated him if he's drinking LA
water he will soon I hope so the IV does
say do you want tap or do you want
sparkling you're like
tap that's so sad but also also it is
kind of I don't know when you're eating
in a night a nice restaurant and people
are like the woo girls you are kind of
like do not there is a little bit going
it's about to have a kid I'm kind of
like I had a con I got pinched as a kid
if you were loud in public you got
pinched you learned to be quiet in nice
restaurants there is this thing now
where teenage girls will walk into a
space and it's just for them to do Tik
toks and you are kind of like there's no
respect for like you don't even know
care that anyone is they offered to move
these people and they didn't move like
he was just one of those old jerk offs
who got even they left right after of
course they did this fucking asshole is
just screaming on top of its lungs and
the lady is like saying to the table the
restaurant should have taken care of
this and it's like how many times have
you been here a hundred times I I told
the guy he was wrong to yell at him I
got into it with a little bit but I
realized Jim is so good at handling
these situations cuz I'm kind of shaking
you know and I'm feeling so terrible I
just shut up but handles it just but
also they were like 25 that's
different 14 like these are children
they were kids having a good time and
they weren't being mean even when they
were loud they go sh like they were
trying they were just giggling and
having fun and it's a birthday they sang
Happy Birthday and this miserable
fucking Lech jerk off and his fucking
cryptic fucking shit wife uh that's
exactly what they were they were fucking
old cryptic fucking dead people and he
was a he was a bully because he he would
have not have yelled if that was Chuck
Zito sitting there he would not have
screamed at him like that and I didn't
yell at the he knew there would be no
ramifications I spoke to him but I
didn't yell at him because again I
wouldn't yell at Chuck Zito either so I
can't yell at a 70-year-old guy so you
went up to him like right away or he ta
behind five minutes I couldn't take it
anymore when I saw those girls huddled
and shut I just got so fucking mad I
just said to him I'm like I'm like you
know they were annoying you're right but
you I'm like you didn't have to yell at
them that was you were wrong and he well
thank you for your advice I'm like if
that was a table full I think I said of
Like Rappers or whatever I'm like you
never would have done that and I know it
and you know it you wouldn't have yelled
at men um and then they just got up and
left he was a fucking jerk off I I
literally hope you hit a fucking pole on
the way home
I hat that guy I um I do feel like it's
interesting as like a forward- facing
person like that seemed like it would be
fine I'm always the person that is fight
most people are freeze or flight I'm
always fight like I'm the person who's
like when something's going on like I
always want to get involved yeah and
that's just I think part of our thing
there's I felt that way too I wanted to
say something really bad luckily he
handled up the sister the sister finally
screamed but Nikki Nikki so helpful all
these girls were like happy that we said
something and Nikki goes it's okay she
was a sea
word I'm like shut the fuck up
I didn't they're 14 but she said CW word
she didn't actually say the word so you
know she did it for tonight show set she
kept
laugh and they said you're cool and I'm
like oh yeah it's like the cool ants but
they offered yeah they offered us the
rest of cake you want the rest of the
cake and I did but I couldn't bring home
a 14-year-old's cake I was going to say
you'll end up on a list I can't bring
home a 14year old but the party ended
right after that and they left and then
the birthday girl was there with like
I just felt bad that the guy yelled he
have he could have they had
such I'm very happy that this is the
memory that they will have cuz at least
didn't end with just him going at least
they had people siding with them and
saying it's fine douche and you know
what it's interesting about comedians
like we get so beat up on for so many
things and people say we're bullies and
we make fun of people at the end of the
day our deal is an obsession with
Justice and calling out hypocrisy and
unfairness so it's like you know it's
like even for like defending Trump or
something and people like how could you
do that you're like cuz you guys that
wasn't a fair Jack these are fair
allegations but this one's not like we
just are on the side of Justice always
and that was an unfair that was just
unfair and just being yeah and also
being obsessed like whenever I see
somebody just doing something because it
looks like that's what works on their
side of the or or that's what my hive
says it just kind of annoys we're kind
of we bully the bullies I feel like
that's kind of our thing do you know
what I mean in a weird way like that's
always the person I feel like we go
after in a way and that guy was like a
bully he was a bully because not because
he spoke up or because he was annoyed
cuz they were being a little irritating
but just the way he did it and it's like
you never would have fucking yelled at
certain other people like that and I
Know It pussy and you know it but again
for the same reason I couldn't yell at
him because I wouldn't scream like I
said chug Zito so I wasn't going to yell
at an old guy yeah I spoke to him the
way I would have spoke to anybody else
and let me just ask you of just the the
getting mad at people in traffic like
what comes up like what is it it's it's
a weird is it primordial is it a wound
it's like whenever whenever I hear about
a road rage shooting uhhuh I always have
a let's wait and see
attitude let me see the footage I would
like to know yes he shot him and his
family but how slow are they going
but I mean was there a left turn arrow
or not I want to know what happen I
because it's such you know what it is
it's such pure narcissism when people
are like cutting you off or cutting in
front of you it's such a lack of regard
for that there's other people in the
space but they also know you're going to
get out of the way cuz you don't want to
get in an accident so I have this
leverage I don't let people like I I
mean I'm not going crazy but if we're
all lining up and there's a person
trying to cut in I fucking straight
ahead but he's the same when he flies
whenever he travels I just completely
Restless no but I think there's
something because I've gotten to a point
where I'm kind of like you know what if
you're in such a rush you go for it you
know what going to let you have it if
you're so busy you're right that's the
better way to be because you're going to
live to be 98 because your heart's not
going to stop the rage is never serves
me well never it's never like I'm
texting anyway I have stuff to do it's
never helpful yeah and I think I mean
maybe it's just like living in a major
city like La there's always going to be
those psychos that are on Aderall that
just watch Fast and Furious that have
something to prove it's so fascinating
to me how all the housewives here and I
mean the rich ones with money they're
all on shrooms I love it it's so cute I
didn't know that that was a very big La
thing and and socially accept too very
much so yeah la people are so dumb they
think that plants want what's best for
you like that's their thing like they're
like weed is fine and mushrooms is fine
and it's like you know cocaine comes
from a flour like you know so yes
there's a lot of the micro doing
mushrooms is happening uh I actually did
it a little I had to quit um I was doing
it too much when we were doing the
roasts all the writers were micro doing
mushrooms and it's what it really does
is it it gives you a little more compass
I don't think I need more compassion a
lot of times but um sometimes that's my
thing I took was micro doing mushrooms
and instantly started looking for the
Scientology ships so it was like we had
to we had to cut that out a new C here
it I was like I'm going to go get the
the kids off the Scientology boats and
find Shelley
mavage everyone else was like let's
write jokes about ber Cher I was like
we're finding the kids we're going to
Epstein Island Uber looking for sea or
yeah like it was is like comedian brain
not a match but what it does is it kind
of takes away that voice of like the
inner critic the inner bully and a lot
of these writers that you know were in
the writer rooms be like it just like
makes me like I'm not so hard on myself
and I'd be like I got the jokes you sent
and half the words are misspelled maybe
you should be a little harder on hard on
yourself it's okay maybe the inner
critic was serving you well maybe we
don't want to silence all of them
because you're also three and a half
hours late you know yeah the in critics
can be very helpful yeah and they're
like is just so good for me I'm like I
don't know man you haven't written a new
joke in two years so I think there's
probably a place for it but to do it
daily all the time is that what the
micro doing is is a daily thing well
here's the thing if you're high if
you're micro doing four times a day
that's a dose that's a lot you're on
drugs yeah three four micro does is a
dose then you got to do more and more
your R is very fun by the way I I was
just thinking as we were talking how
good was Robin
TR
Killer really funny on last what a great
great animal had to follow Donell nobody
want yeah nobody wants to go on last she
was great anal great she's an animal and
she took it like a warrior yeah she's
very funny I just was thinking like
because she had to go on last and nobody
likes that at a roast CU every concept
has been destroyed it's fucking dead
she's a beast I loved watching her she's
such a beast she's been a beast for so
long such a great joke writer and
something else I love about her is like
like you know it's like she's trans like
it's easy to make fun of herself she
still plays to the top of her
intelligence never lazy never sloppy
never kind of like oh I know I could
make a trans joke and be trans is that
why her name is Robin trans you know
what she has a no it's
just she she has this joke she was I'm
such a lazy trans woman my Gmail is
still Robert TR at
G it's like everyone's like in such a
rush to change everything she like I
don't want to like call the phone
company all she's just like so funny she
isun so but that's a trans person with
irony isn't it just great to watch and
not taking everything so serious
everything doesn't have such weight and
magnitude and by the way and I really
want to have her on the roast not only
because she's a animal you know she's
been doing the roast battles forever but
also to show that like most trans people
have a sense of humor about all of that
we make fun of men we make fun of women
where are they like come through
yeah they're not on Twitter fighting
with everybody so it's people like all
trans people are so uptight and I'm like
no the cool ones aren't on Twitter
yelling at everyone trying to get people
fired in the Human Resources office they
have better things to do they have lives
they're not thinking about it so I've
never met people where the megaphone
these people who are behind this
megaphone I haven't met one of them I've
only guess seen them on Twitter I don't
know but trans people are no different
than anybody else no different than any
other group Men Women racial this group
there most people are fine and then
there's a loud group that wants to to
pretend to be upset because it's
empowering and then there's a group
who's legit upset yeah um it's any other
group it's like people make trans and
umbrella term when it's not like it's
not at all an umbrella term like if I'm
transgender it literally means change
the gender you were assigned at Birth
yeah hello and now you're putting it
like in my base where I had to go for me
where I had to go and get a diagnosis I
had to do all this and now you're just
calling yourself trans it's not thatas
you know I learned how to make eggs yeah
egg whites for him cuz he eats like he's
got AIDS it's fucking
crazy what does that mean he's magic
John I mean who ate who eats egg
whites Tom Hanks in Philadelphia I don't
know exactly you're terrible yeah why
are you eating egg Whit I don't no I
just s gross CU it looks like cum I just
throw the egg whites on my back and they
cool off I'll eat
all the vitamins are in the yellow part
I know but I'm afraid of high
cholesterol for my heart cholesterol is
not as bad for you as I think everybody
says are you on something for I'm a
little bit of what what rest Strat
whatever it's called a little very small
just zic just go all the way dud get on
that get a tummy tuck I don't want a
tummy tuck I'm joking I don't want a zic
see she has awful can we send him to
that doctor in
Boston please yeah she's always got the
worst suggestions just to shut me up
just it off go see doctor now you have
to lose
weight God I can't I can't with this has
been our first interview too this really
fun oh my God y are the best I can talk
to you forever yeah so happy we're doing
you it's just like I don't know it's
really heartwarming it's giving me so
much um Faith it's like you know um I'm
going to out you guys for a second for
being the cutest when I having a baby
shower was really hard for me cuz it's
weird to get attention around something
that's not being a performer like when
you guys get married it's going feel
weird yeah cuz you're kind of like like
why is everyone so happy for me I
haven't made you know I haven't like
earned this or something and when you
guys came to the baby shower it made so
like me so much to me in and everyone I
mean my you know our friends are animals
like they want nothing more than to just
say horrible things about people and
they were just like they're the cutest
and then you guys sent me the cutest
little baby basket like you're just such
a dream I love being at your baby shower
it was my first baby shower ever oh gosh
it was kind of a mine too it was kind of
a weird it's awkward and weird it it was
just like perfect I just stood in the
corner and ate I just stood in the
corner and ate little diaper cookies and
I looked at Andrew Schultz's wife and
I'm like your husband makes so much more
money than I
do he's doing so much
better and she was there alone and you
were there with someone that loves you
so he sold out the garden twice in a day
I was pretty amazing it's it's like it's
or in two days it's like Andrew sh yeah
it's like guys like that or even Dane
never I thought got the credit he
deserved for what he did on social Medi
term yeah and and when you look at what
Schultz has done and like what guys are
doing with it now it's like anyone who
denies that that's the best way to go is
crazy and I think for a while they're
you know you go like oh gosh promoting
yourself it's so lame that's not what we
do and it's kind of like it's a part of
the job now and you know and it's like
getting over that shame of like no one I
think the hardest thing for me about
being a comedian is when I post
something not thinking is Jim Norton
going to see this and think I'm such of
loser every time I post something I'm
like if Chris Rock sees this I'm never
going to be able to look him in the eye
again but like they're not buying
tickets the hardest part is to stop
wanting to get comedians to not make fun
of your posts yes because we're all the
same we all want to have integrity we
all want to succeed and by the way
richer prior and George Carlin did The
Tonight Show Bill Hicks did Letterman
like those shows are only done to
promote and by the way and and and prior
didn't go on the tonight's show and say
pussy or he he talked according to
network and so did George and so did
every they played The game everyone does
you can still have integrity and and
still be smart and promote I mean I
remember like when I was coming up
opening for comics on the road like I um
opened for a comic who he had he would
sell out Wednesday through Sunday he
would do two shows Wednesday night two
shows Sunday so that's I'm an idiot with
math is that eight shows he would sell
at eight shows as Craig Shoemaker but he
would do he'd be sold out for the year
and he would do the cards so as his
opener I would drop the cards and it
would he had a mailing list and he would
send out these note cards postcards
saying I'm coming that was like the
first iteration of it and it really
worked and I watched him show up at 4:00
put down the pencils do the whole thing
and I thought it was cool I thought it
was impressive but now all of a sudden
if you're talking into a phone you're
like oh God I feel like such a
narcissist like I feel so because why
why is why is embarrassing to try
because we all we don't mind failing but
the most humiliating thing is when
people go oh you're trying to it's
almost like I don't like to dress nice
because then people go oh you actually
think think you look good don't you um
and what's wrong with we we're all
trying I'm trying to entertain you I'm
trying to make you like I'm trying to
make you laugh I'm trying to make you
like me I guess I'm a try hard and if
you're not into that fine you know I
wish you wore a Blazer at least
sometimes thanks for getting the point
of what we're talking
about that's my life that's right there
that's aw I would love for him to dress
nicer I by the way just have to share
this one story that is my favorite
favorite Jim Norton story we were at a a
premiere of I think it was might have
been Jeff or maybe it's like Jeff Ross's
book or his special remember Comedy
Central would have like premieres for
stuff you know and we were at some like
the roosevel hotel and um Jim Norton had
put me gave me my first like HBO spot on
a show called down and dirty which is
such a big deal um for me and I'll never
be able to thank you enough for that and
so we're kind of talk I'm still like
still Jim Norton and I'm still just
awkwardly like standing next to you and
an agent came up uh I know exactly what
his name is but I won't say it and uh so
you just had this you know big series
come out on HBO and the agent's like hey
Jim how are how are you man like with
that predatory and you know Vibe and Jim
just went where were you 10 years ago
when I needed
you I love it well here's the great news
I need you again so you're around I'm
dying was just I was like damn like I
physically like like R out of frame
laughing so I'm never seen dead serious
and the guy walked away and just like
nothing that was
it that was it he was like just kidding
man that was
just was like oh my God he is my hero
yeah yeah well brass balls brass balls
yes well you know I love you so much
Nikki and Jim Nikki at Nikki and Jim
NYC yeah sorry NYC and when it stuff is
already starting to come up we're
already going to start posting stuff
we're on socials you're on Instagram now
yeah yes it's m Nicki Norton Ms Miss
Nikki Norton M
SS anything to leave the mister out
please see I like this trans woman is
more like it's Miss not miss
m
anything I had that once in my fly
ticket oh mrss oh oh my God it's like
gender dysphoria but on paper you're
like Mister no thank you but when you're
married it's Ms or that Ms says misses
so actually I should have been a Miss
you're the misses the Miss I just can't
do no Ms is I think Ms is ambiguous Miss
single Ms is single mrss is married and
Ms is either or it does it doesn't State
your marital status okay Jesus Christ
yeah I know I love being back up on
Instagram though it's it's it's great to
be back on social media cuz now I can
finally interact with the world so not
having it I loved it too I loved being
private I love not having any social
media being completely off the grid was
great but being back I love it it's fun
and this is all and this is again edge
of my seat cannot wait I hope people
like it it's just it's just our dumb
life and it's fun and some of it but
some of it's real and some of it's just
us being home and this is how we
interact America sweethearts well a
should we kiss for that no that's not
how you do it should we kiss for on a
show all right I love she's trying too
hard to be real and dignified it's
boring you know just talk to the people
what are you doing all
right what are you doing no you're right
where were you 10 years ago when he
needed you he probably wish he could
have met
me I love you guys thank you so much for
doing this Nikki 2k's and Jim
NYC cannot wait come back soon please
thank you I love you and I
no ride elephants we love you and then
you'll be on tour next year yes starting
February fantastic love
[Music]
[Applause]
you